careful out there it is
okay resistance ladies and dudes the KPA
has invaded America and it's time to
grab your guns your high school
chemistry notes and your superior
hacking skills you learned at Khan
Academy push them out of your hood yes
home front the revolution beta has
dropped on xbox one and no amount of
Patrick Swayze can save you but these
top four things to do in home front can
number for loot scavenge and build you
have an extensive arsenal of explosives
hacking devices Molotov cocktails and
pipe bombs that can be crafted in the
field said devices come in many forms
teddy bear RC car and manually detonated
to name a few they require ingredients
which can be found on car wrecks
destroyed kpa vehicles high-level
soldiers and around ammo caches pick
them up and craft turn down times always
a good early investment in the skill
tree is the breaker skill under brains
which lets you scavenge more from
vehicles and wrecks and don't forget you
will run out of ammo frequently if you
don't scavenge bodies number three mix
up your tactics there are lots of ways
to go after your targets so get on Mike
and let your team know what the deal is
in much the same way as payday 2 stell
seems to be a high level skill and
getting a suppressor comes down to luck
of the draw but you can always mark
targets with your camera and go full
knife commando if you're not going to
sell the route mix up your arsenal some
missions such as infiltration benefit
greatly from long-range sniping when the
KPA hits the fan employ the proper
craftable devices distraction devices
immediately draw aggro hacking devices
turn enemy vehicles on their own troops
and pipe bombs well you know they do the
exploding when it comes to tactics be a
team player and be adaptable number to
understand the loot system after every
single round head over to the armory and
buy a crate the vast majority of gear
contains stats so once you have a gun
you like don't neglect clothing items
it's not just for vanity a plus-10
stealth B plus twenty percent stealth
armor and maybe get lucky with a
suppressor or a cool barrel attachment
might just get you through that tough
encounter finally Hypno's crate
might just get you one of those crazy
weapons such as a super blunderbuss or
America rocket launcher did I say this
is a loot driven experience because it
is and finally number one field strip
your guns all the time any weapon you
take into the field is actually a weapon
category and the good old CryEngine will
let you swap between them on the fly I
particularly enjoyed the marksman rifles
which can be adapted from close range
support to long-range marksmanship to
long-range bolt action action if you
aren't constantly field tripping weapons
based on objective and map you're doing
it wrong and that's it for the top four
things to do in the homefront beta what
are your tips and tricks are you
enjoying the beta let us know in the
comments below and for more coverage of
homefront the revolution I can stay
tuned to gamespot com got beat thought
tonight haha